[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه من العربيه
نستعرض ونرصد معكم ابرز المستجدات في
العناوين
يقر ضمنيا بسيطره روسيا على باخموت بعد
تجميدها بالكامل
يهنئ مقاتلي فاجنر
ترحيب دولي بالهدنه الانسانيه في السودان
وبلينكن يناشد طرفي الصراع لاسكات المدافع
الهيئه السعوديه للفضاء تعلن اكتمال
الاستعدادات النهائيه قبل انطلاق رائدي
الفضاء السعوديين
يتحدى ويقتحم باحه المسجد الاقصى مجددا
صباح الخير البدايه من السجال الروسي
الاوكراني حول السيطره على مدينه باخموت
حيث اقر الرئيس الاوكراني فولدميرنسكي
ضمنيا ان بلاده فقدت سيطرتها على مدينه
بخموت شرقي البلاد بعد معارك مع القوات
الروسيه دامت لاشهر طويله وخلال لقائه
بالرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن في هيروشيما
على هامش قمه مجموعات السبع رد زيلينسكي
على سؤال حول استمرار سيطره بلاده على
باخموت وقال لا اعتقد هذا واضاف زيلينسكي
انا باخ موت المدمره هي الان في قلوب
الاوكرانيين واشار الى ان المعارك دمرت
بخموت بشكل شبهي كامل وان الجنود
الاوكرانيين بذلوا كل جهد في محاولات
للحفاظ على المدينه
اعتقد اننا فقدنا السيطره على مدينه لكن
عليكم ان تفهموا انها تحولت الى لا شيء
الروس دمروها بالكامل لا يوجد فيها بناء
الامر ماساوي اليوم بامكاننا القول ان
باخموت فقط في قلوبنا لا يوجد شيء هناك
الا الدمار والكثير من القتلى الروس الذين
اتوا الينا الاوكرانيون الذين دافعوا عن
بخموت قاموا بعمل قوي وبالطبع نحن نقدرهم
على جهودهم رائعه
لكن المتحدث باسم الرئاسه الاوكرانيه قال
في وقت لاحق لم يؤكد سيطره القوات الروسيه
على مدينه بخموت المحاصره في شرق اوكرانيا
واوضح
سؤال المراسل
الروس قالوا انهم سيطروا على باخموت وكان
رد الرئيس لا اعتقد ذلك واضاف المتحدث
بهذه الطريقه نفي الرئيس الاوكراني ما
وصفه بالاستيلاء على بخموت في المقابل هنا
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين ان اقوات
فاجنر والجيش الروسي بعد اعلان سيطرتهم
على مدينه باخموت واضاف البيان ان الرئيس
الروسي اصدر توجيهاته برفع اسماء ابطال
العمليه المتميزين لتقليدهم اوسمه الشرف
التي استحقوها هذا وكانت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه اعلنت في وقت سابق انه ان نتيجه
للعمليات الهجوميه لوحدات فاجنر وبدعم من
الطيران ومدفعيه المجموعه الجنوبيه للقوات
الروسيه انه تم الانتهاء من السيطره على
مدينه باخ موت
ربما لنتحدث عن اخر التطورات حول باخموت
واخر الاعلانات يعني راينا اعلان وتاكيد
من الجانب الروسي من موسكو وتاكيد ودعم
ايضا من الانفصاليين حول السيطره على
باخموت ولكن لنستذكر معك رائد المراحل
التي مرت بها باخموت في التسعه اشهر
الماضيه
نهارك طيب مره اخرى فاطمه بالفعل يعني امس
اعلنت السيطره الكامله على الحدود
الاداريه لمدينه باخمت من قبل قوات
فاغنريف غينيا اعلن هذه السيطره وسط صمت
من قبل موسكو والدفاع الروسيه والكرملين
حتى ساعه متاخره من ليله امس حتى ظهرت
التهنئه من الرئيس الروسي بلادي مربوطين
الذي هنا مقاتلي فاقنر على شجاعتهم ووعدهم
بتقليدهم باوسمه الشجاعه كما ان الدفاع
الروسيه تلت بذلك الاعتراف او
الاعلان السيطره الكامل على مدينه باخموت
واكدت بانها ما زالت تطرد القوات
الاوكرانيه من الاجنحه للعوده بتاريخ
المعارك تسعه اشهر كانت محتدمه فيها
المعارك بدا جيش الروسي وقوات فاجنر
بتطويق المدينه بداوا يقتربون من المناطق
الجنوبيه ومن ثم توسيع الطوق الى المناطق
الجنو الشرقيه ومن ثم ايضا الوصول الى
المناطق
الجنوبيه الشرقيه الشماليه ليصبح الهلال
كامل
ويحاولون التقدم لتطويق المدينه اكثر من
ناحيه الجنوبيه الغربيه ومن الشماليه
الغربيه وبداوا يدخلون في العمق من الثلاث
محاور المحور الشمالي والجنوبي والشرقي
ويدفعون القوات الاوكرانيه للانسحاب اول
باول من عمق المدينه ويسيطرون على الحيتل
والحي والشارع تل والحي وتلو الشارع حتى
وصلوا الى اخر المدينه الجزء الغربي
وتحسنت القوات الاوكرانيه في الجزء الغربي
وباتو يسيطرون على كل مئه ومئتين
وثلاثمائه متر ويدفعون القوات الاوكرانيه
للانسحاب حتى امس واعلان السيطره الكامله
حتى الان جيش الاوكراني لم يقر بهذه
السيطره الا ان يعني القوات الاوكراني
الروسيه
بدات تظهر فيديوهات لاعلام فاجنر في جميع
نواحي وجوانب المدينه لابد ان
تخرج ايضا من افراد الجيش الاوكراني يعني
يقرون بسقوط طباخ ولكن لانها
منتشر مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي طبعا لا
نعرف صحتها ولكن ساعود اليك رائد ابقى معي
كرما انتقل الى كييف والصحفي محمد البابا
يعني يقول بان بخموت لم تعد بايدينا
ولكنها في قلوبنا وبعد ذلك يخرج المتحدث
باسم
لم يقر بسقوط بخموت الى ماذا يشير ذلك
اولا الرئيس الاوكراني وفلادي وبحسب
المكتب الرئاسي هو هو اجاب على سؤال هل
سيطرت فاجنر على مدينه باقمت فكان جوابه
انا اعتقد لا هذا يعني ان الرئيس
الاوكراني لم يقل ان القوات الاوكرانيه لم
تسيطر او فقدت السيطره على مدينه وهذا
الكلام بحسب المتحدث باسم المكتب الرئاسي
شرح طبيعه السؤال والجواب وحتى هذه اللحظه
معظم المكاتب الاعلاميه للجيش الاوكراني
المتحدثين باسم الجيش الاوكراني قياده
الجيش القياده الشماليه للجيش الاوكراني
وقياده القوات المسلحه البريه جميعهم
يقولون ان منطقه ليتاكو وهي تقع في جنوب
غرب مدينه تحت السيطره القوات الاوكرانيه
وقبل حوالي ساعه يعني خرج احد الناشطين
وهو الشيخ سعيد من داخل احد الاحياء في
مدينه باقمت وقال ان هذه المنطقه تسيطر
عليها القوات الاوكرانيه يعني هناك تضارب
معلومات بشكل كبير الجانب الاوكراني بشكل
تام وبحسب جميع البيانات ان تكون اصبحت
مدينه ضخمه بشكل كامل ولكن يعني هناك نقطه
جغرافيه يعني متداخل هي منطقه جنوب غرب
مدينه هي متداخله مع اطراف المدينه ربما
الجانب الاوكراني يجلس في تلك المنطقه
ويقول انه لا يزال داخل مدينه وايضا الجيش
الاوكراني لا يكون بعمليات هجوميه داخل
وسط مدينه باخم او في الاحياء في مدينه
ضخمه بل هو يحاول فك الطوق عن مدينه ضخمه
في المنطقه الجنوبيه والمنطقه الشماليه
والجيش الاوكراني تقدم حوالي عشرين كيلو
متر يعني من الناحيه الجنوبيه والشماليه
خلال ثلاثه او اربعه اسابيع وتراجعت
القوات
الاوكراني في تلك المناطق ولكن اعود اليك
رائد يعني لنتحدث عن ماذا تبقى من ربما
دنيتك وهذه المقاطعه المهمه من محاور ومدن
لتسيطر عليها تماما وبشكل كامل القوات
الروسيه
هذا سؤال هام جدا فاطمه لانه ما خلف باخمت
وما قبل باقمت من نحو العاصمه اذا يعني
نظرنا الى ما قبل باخموت من يعني من ناحيه
العاصمه فنعلم بان هناك المدن في شمال غرب
المقاطعه مدينه افديفكا مدينه مارينكا
ايضا
حتى بيسكي التي تمت السيطره عليها سابقا
هناك في اطرافها معارك ضاريه في هذه المدن
ما بين الجيش الروسي وما بين القوات
الاوكرانيه التي ما زالت متمركزه في هذه
المدن وتقصف قلب العاصمه بشكل يومي الحديث
عن وصول اسلحه متطوره لجانب الاوكراني
وقصف مستمر للمدينه هناك ضحايا من
المدنيين بشكل يومي الحديث عن قتيل او
عشره قتله تصل ما بين قتيل الى عشره قتله
بشكل يومي اضافه الى اعداد من الاصابات
حيث الاسلحه المتطوره التي حصلت من الغرب
لايدي المقاتلين في هذه المدن القوات
الروسيه تقدمت يوم امس عده مئات من
المتراء من الامطار في محور مارن في
الناحيه الغربيه تحاول القوات الروسيه
تطويق مدينه
على نفس شاكله تطويق مدينه باخمه سابقا
وتخوض معارك ضاريه في جميع هذه المحاور
وتتقدم ببطء فاطمه وان كان هذا التقدم جدا
بطيء لكنه ملموس على الارض ولصالح الجيش
الروسي طيب اعود اليك محمد لاختم معك ربما
يعني ما ان
اقر الاوكراني بسقوط باخموت ماذا يعني ذلك
للجيش الاوكراني
لا يعني اي شيء القوات الاوكرانيه تعلم
طبيعه المعارك وهذا ما كان يقوله سيركس
قائد القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه ليله امس
دخل القنوات الاوكرانيه كان يقول انه يعني
في حتى لو خرجت القوات الاوكرانيه والتي
ستخرج عاجلا ام اجلا من الحي او المربع
السكني الذي لا تتمركز به القوات
الاوكرانيه هذا لا يعني خساره معركه او
هذا لا يعني تغيير ديموغرافي هل هو الجيش
الاوكراني يستعد للهجوم المضاد ولكن
لماذا استمروا بالقتال بشكل يعني كبير جدا
على مدى تسعه اشهر الماضيه
استنساخ لمجموعه فاكينر التي خسرت اكثر من
70% من قدرتها العسكريه ونتيجه هذه
الخساره فاجنر ستخرج من مدينه وستخرج من
ساحات القتال يوم الخميس المقبل يعني بعد
اربعه ايام
ستنسحب القوات لتسلم الويه الجيش الروسي
مدينه بخمه بشكل كامل وهذا يعني ان يعني
المهمه التي اوكلت الى قد اتم وتراجع خوفا
من الهجوم المضاد الذي يعني من المتوقع
احد اهم الركائز ستكون استعاده باخمه وليس
تشانس
وبهذه يكون قد رمى الكره في ملعب وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه حتى لا يتحمل اي تبعات
مستقبليه خاصه اكثر من 40 الف جندي روسي
ويعني من مجموعات قتلوا منذ بدايه العام
حتى الان بحسب بيانات وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه طيب شكرا لك جزيل الشكر منك
البابا ومن دنيتك مراسل العربيه رائد
الاخبار
في تطورات المعارك مشاهدينا افاد المتحدث
باسم وزاره الدفاع الروسيه بان القوات
الروسيه تمكنت من كشف تحركات لوائين
اوكرانيين وكاتبه واحدثت اضرارا نتيجه
اطلاق النار على العدو على حد وصفه واضافت
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه انه من خلال
استخبارات مجموعات قوات المركز تم اكتشاف
تحرك الافراد على معدات اللواء الميكانيكي
66 ولواء المشاه 58 لقوات الجيش الاوكراني
والفوج 15 للحرس الوطني الاوكراني مؤكده
ان الجيش الاوكراني تكبد خسائر كبيره في
الافراد والمعدات واضافت الدفاع الروسيه
ان طاقم نظام اطلاق الصواريخ المتعدده
قام بضرب مواقع الجيش الاوكراني في اتجاه
كريسني ليمان ولا يزال قائد قوات فاجنر
يبغيني برغوجين يوجه انتقاداته للجيش
الروسي اخرها قال ان اعداد المقاتلين لدى
مجموعه فاجنر في مدينه بخموت كان من
المفترض ان تشكل
ضعف الذين قاتلوا بالفعل كما اكد ايضا ان
الاسلحه التي كان من المفترض ان تستلمها
قوته تعادل 27 ضعف الاسلحه التي استلمناها
مضيفا ان اعداد القذائف التي استلمها
تعادل 11% فاصله خمسه فقط من العدد المتفق
عليه مع الدفاع الروسيه وعلى هامش قمه
مجموعه السبعه المقامه في اليابان التقى
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن بالرئيس
الاوكراني حيث اكد الرئيس الامريكي ان او
اكد لفلاديمير زيلينسكي عن ارساله لحزمه
جديده من الاسلحه
وقال بايدن ان حزمه الاسلحه الامريكيه
لاوكرانيا ستشمل ذخيره ومدفعيه وعربات
مصفحه مؤكدا ان بلاده ستواصل دعم اوكرانيا
لمواجهه روسيا في هذه الحرب امر رئيس
الفرنسي ايمانويل قال ان حضوره او حضور
نظيره الاوكراني في قمه مجموعه السبع في
هيروشيما هي وسيله لبناء السلام واضاف
ماكرون ان وضع طائره فرنسيه في تصرف
زيلينسكي او وضعها في تصرفه لنقله اولا
الى قمه جامعات الدول العربيه ثم الى
مجموعه السبع في اليابان ويظهر عمل فرنسا
على بناء السلام والبحث عن حلول كما دعا
ماكرون الى عدم الاكتفاء بوقف محتمل
لاطلاق النار بين كييف وموسكو معتبرا ان
الصراعات المجمده قد تكون حروبا في الغد
وحول الوضع في بخموت اكد ماكرون ان الامر
متروك للسلطات الاوكرانيه للحديث عن تقدم
قواتها على الارض
الى الصراع في السودان حيث قالت السعوديه
والولايات المتحده في بيان مشترك ان طرفي
الصراع في السودان الجيش السوداني وقوه
الدعم السريع وقع على اتفاق لوقف اطلاق
النار لمده سبعه ايام وجاء في البيان ان
وقف اطلاق النار سيدخل حيز التنفيذ بعد 48
ساعه من التوقيع ويمكن تمديده بموافقه
الطرفين طبعا واضاف البيان الجانبين تتفق
على ايصال وتوزيع المساعدات الانسانيه
واستعاده الخدمات الاساسيه بالاضافه الى
سحب القوات من المستشفيات والمرافق العامه
الاساسيه كما اتفق الطرفان على تسهيل
المرور الامن لمقدمي المساعدات الانسانيه
مما يسمح بتدفق المساعدات من دون عوائق من
موانئ الدخول الى السكان المحتاجين واضاف
البيان ان الاتفاق ستدعمه اليه مراقبه وقف
اطلاق النار المدعوم دوليا من قبل
السعوديه والولايات المتحده
لا يخفى عليكم
حرص المملكه العربيه السعوديه وخادم
الحرمين الشريف والعهد على السودان وعلى
استقرار السودان وعلى امن السودان
ونسال الله ان شاء الله ان يرفع هذه الغمه
على السودان وعن اهلها ان شاء الله
والحقيقه شاكرين على موقفكم هذا اليوم على
تعاونكم في الوصول الى هذا الاتفاق واهل
السودان منتظرين هذا وهذا ان شاء الله في
خير كثير يعني تعرفون انه الدم هذا غالي
والدم السوداني غالي وانتم تاخذونه اكثر
يعني اكثر من اي احد ان شاء الله هذا
الاتفاق سيكون بصيص امل لاهل السودان
بالذات اهل الخرطوم في انه يعني يستطيعون
ان يعالجون امورهم الانسانيه في هذه سبعه
ايام وان شاء الله تمتد الى اكثر وان شاء
الله تكون خطوه في الطريق الصحيحه بارك
الله فيكم وشكرا لكم على تجاوبكم وشكرا
على موقفكم هذا وان شاء الله يعني ما نرى
من بعد هذا الا كل الخير للسودان واهل
السودان ان شاء الله
وتعليقا على اعلاني وقف اطلاق النار في
السودان قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انتن
بلنكن في تغريده له عبر تويتر قال انه حان
الوقت لاسكات المدافع والسماح بوصول
المساعدات الانسانيه من دون عوائق وناشد
الوزير الامريكي في تغريده في تغريدته
ناشد الجانبين للتمسك بهذا الاتفاق مؤكدا
ان انظار العالم تراقب هذا ورحبت قوى
الحريه والتغيير في السودان باتفاق الهدنه
ودعت في بيان الى الالتزام الكامل باعلان
مبادئ جدا وباتفاق وقف اطلاق النار قصير
الامد وبالترتيبات الانسانيه وعربت ايضا
عن امرها بان يشكل هذا الاتفاق خطوه في
طريق وقف الحرب بشكل كامل اما من جانبه
وصف رئيس حزب المؤتمر السوداني
وصف توقيع اتفاق الهدنه الانسانيه بخطوه
ايجابيه اخرى في معالجه الكارثه الانسانيه
في السودان وشكر حزب المؤتمر السوداني شكر
السعوديه والولايات المتحده لتيسير الو
لهذه الخطوه المهمه مناشدا المجتمع الدولي
والاقليمي بمواصله استنفار الجهود
وتنسيقها لتقديم المساعدات الانسانيه اما
في تطورات المعارك مشاهدينا قال ياسر
العطا مساعد قائد الجيش السوداني عبد
الفتاح البرهان قال في لقاء مع التلفزيون
السوداني انه تم القضاء على اكثر من 85%
من قوات ما وصفه بالتمرد الموجود في
البلاد مشيرا الى ان ما يحدث في البلاد
حرب ولها تبعات ودعا ياسر العطا مساعد
قائد الجيش السوداني دعا المواطنين
السودانيين الى التحلي بالصبر معتبرا ان
الحل قريب واضاف ان الموقف الان لا يتطلب
تسليح المواطنين لكن من يتسلح فليتسلح
لحمايه نفسه وهذا حقه على حد تعبيره افادت
نقابه اطباء السودان مشاهدينا بمقتل 18
مدنيا جراء المعارك بين الجيش والدعم
السريع وفي مدينه نيالا في ولايه جنوب
دارفور خلال اليومين الماضيين هذا وكان
الن زاع المسلح بين الطرفين في مدينه
نيالا ادى الى مقتل واصابه المئات من
المدنيين خلال الاسابيع الاخيره الماضيه
الصراع في السودان في شهره الثاني خريطه
المواجهه تتسع وتتسع معها معاناه
السودانيين مقاتله الجيش شنت هجمات على
ضواحي العاصمه الخرطوم وجنوبي ام درمان
اضافه الى شمالي الخرطوم بحري ووقعت
اشتباكات ايضا في منطقه شارع النيل وسط
الخرطوم وفي اقليم دارفور كانت مدينه يالا
عاصمه ولايه جنوب دارفور مسرحا لمواجهه
عسكريه ومعارك داميه في المدينه حيث اندلع
قتال بري هناك قوه الجيش اعلنت سيطرتها
على المدينه بعد اشتباكات مع قوات الدعم
السريع واستهداف حاميه النيال العسكريه
كما شهدت مدينه زلنجي في ولايه وسط دارفور
اشتباكات مسلحه بين قوات الدعم السريع
والجيش وبينما يدخل الصراع اسبوعه السادس
تحصي البلاد قتلاها فبحسب نقابه الاطباء
السودانيين تجاوز عدد القتل 850 شخصا
مدنيا
فيما اصيب اكثر من
4390 شخصا حصيله الضحايا قد تكون اعلى
بكثير وفق اطباء خصوصا في ظل صعوبه الوصول
الى جميع المستشفيات تحديدا خارج العاصمه
لحصر جميع الوفيات او الاصابات بدقه
من الخرطومه عن الصحفي عمار ابو شيبه اهلا
بك معنا عمار اذا هدنا موقعه من الطرفين
بواسطه سعوديه امريكيه من المفترض ان تبدا
يوم غد في هذه الاثناء ماذا رصدتم على ارض
المعركه يعني هل هناك تصعيد ومحاوله يعني
كسب اي مكاسب على الارض هناك ام هناك ربما
هدوء نسبي في هذه الساعات الاخيره قبل
الهدنه
اهلا بك فاطمه واهلا بالمشاهدين الكرام
نعم منذ صباح الباكر يعني بدات هنالك عدد
من طائرات الاستطلاع الطابعه لسلاح
السوداني ترصد عدد من المواقع على الارض
هنا في وسط العاصمه الخرطوم وفي مدينه
بحري وفي مدينه ام درمان وبحسب مصادر
الميدانيه ايضا تحدثنا اليها واشارت الى
وقوع اشتباكات خفيفه في منطقه القصر
الرئاسي وهذه المنطقه التي لم تكن تشهد
اشتباكات منذ عده ايام عادت فيها امس
الاشتباكات ولكن بشكل لا يرتقي الى ذلك
المستوى العالي من الاشتباكات الثقيله
الذي دارت على اثره عدد من المعارك
الكبيره في منطقه الخرطوم جنوب ومنطقه
ايضا كذلك
ام درمان في الجانب الغربي ومحيط الاذاعه
والتلفزيون في وسط البلد القديمه خلفي في
الصوره نشاهد عدد من اعمده الدخان التي
تتصاعد فاطمه جراء هذه الاشتباكات منذ
الصباح اليوم الباكر المصادر الميدانيه
التي تحدثنا اليها اشاره الى انها لم ترقى
الى المستوى العنيف ولكنها ايضا خلفت عدد
من الحرائق وخلفت عدد من اعمده الدخان
التي تتصاعد بشكل واضح ومباشر منذ الصباح
الباكر اي قبل ساعتين او اكثر من عمر هذا
المباشر تبدو الحركه رغم ذلك طبيعيه ويبدو
ان الشارع ايضا كذلك تاثر باتفاق جده
الاخير وهذا الاتفاق المحدود لعدد من
النقاط المهمه وما فيها ايضا كذلك من
ترتيبات انسانيه
ومحاوله لفتح الممرات الامنه وواقف اطلاق
النار طوال هذه المده نعم عمار يعني هل
هناك تفاؤل في الداخل حول هذه الهدنه يعني
على خلاف ما رايناه في السابق من خروقات
للهدنات وخروقات للاتفاقيات ولكن هذه
المره هناك فرقه رقابه من الجانب السعودي
والامريكي للالتزام بهذه الهدنه بالتالي
كيف يعني تقيم الوضع والنظرات لهذه الهدنه
نعم هنالك يبدو ان هناك تفاؤلا واضحا خاصه
بعد ان وجد الاتفاق بشكل واضح ترحيبا من
القوى السياسيه
الموقعه لاتفاق الايطالي وايضا كذلك عدد
من الشخصيات السياسيه التي رحبت بهذا
الاتفاق منذ بدايه توقيعه في الصباح
الباكر ومن ثم اعلقوا عليه بشكل واضح عدد
من المنابر والمواقع على مستوى الشارع
السوداني ومن خلال حركه سفيريه على
المواقع الالكترونيه بدات التعليقات تنهال
نحو هذا الاتفاق باعتبارها املا جديدا بعد
عده هدن سبقت لم يتم الالتزام بها ويبدو
هنا ان هذه المره ان الاتفاق يشمل عده
نقاط مهمه من ضمنها اليه المراقبه لهذا
الاتفاق وهذا وضح جاليه من خلال توقيع
الاتفاق الاخير يبدو الامل الان اكبر من
خلال هذا الاتفاق باعتبار اننا دخلنا في
الشهر الثاني من عمر هذه الحرب وكثير جدا
من الماسي وكثير جدا من المتاعب والمصاعب
التي من خلالها اصبحت الحياه صعبه وحتى
الذين ما زالوا باقون هنا في العاصمه
الخرطوم اصبح عمليه التكيف مع الحرب تبدو
صعبه اكبر من عمليه ربما العوده من جديد
للحياه نعم شكرا جزيلا لك من الخرطوم
الصحفي عمار ابو شيبه
مشاهدينا بعد رحله استغرقت سته ايام مشيا
على الاقدام وصل الى جنوب السودان اكبر
عائله تتكون من 19 شخصا غالبيتهم من
النساء والاطفال قدمه من مدينه نيالا
غربيه السودان نتيجه لتجدد الاشتباكات
المسلحه بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع العربيه رصدت اوضاع هذه العائله
واعدت العرض التالي
رحله النجاه
استقرقت نحو 16 يوما مشيا على الاقدام
قضتها هذه العائله المكونه من 19 شخصا
تقريبا
جميعهم من النساء والاطفال
بعدما فقدوا زويهم ورجالهم في الاحداث
التي شهدتها مدينه نيله غربيه السودان
حصلت لنا المشاكل
كملوا رجالنا ونزعنا جينا بحري الغزال
وحالنا بالبلبه ندور الغطى وندور الاكل
ونذور الشراء وندور محلنا محل السكون
لم تكن رحله الفرار عمليه سحله خاصه
لشرائح ضعيفه كالنساء والاطفال
الحسن والخوف ظاهران على الوجوه
اما الذاكره فلا تنسى مشاهد الحرب واصوات
الرصاص حسنا لنا المشاكل بالليل ومرقنا
ونزعنا
قطعت هذه العائله نحو 16 يوما مشيا
بالاقدام من مدينه نيالا بولايه غرب
دارفور الى ان وصلوا الى منطقه الضئين ومن
ثم وصلوا الى هذا المكان كما تبدو الصوره
الصوره هنا تبدو حزينه اذ تحمل الكثير من
المعاس والمعاناه
فلا الطعام يكفي ولا المشاكل مغطاه
فالحياه هنا تفتقر الى ابسط مكوناتها من
يارا وتعبانين وما عندنا اكل وما عندنا ما
عندنا غطى وما عندنا ملابس ملابسنا
لابسينها الناس نوعاني ستظل هي الكلمه
التي يرددها الجميع هنا الى ان تنقضي
حاجتهم او تنجلي مصيبتهم وبين هذا وذاك
سيظل صوت ايقاف الحرب هو صوت الجميع
مبيور شيريلو لقناتي العربيه والحدث
حدود جنوب السودان والسودان
الاطراف بتجيج الاوضاع في البلاد
[موسيقى]
احييكم من جديد قال الرئيس التونسي قيس
سعيد ان ندره الخبز في بعض المناطق في
البلاد وفقدان بعض المواد الاساسيه يهدف
الى تاجيج الاوضاع في تونس تصريحات سعيد
جاءت خلال لقائه بقصر قرطاج امس وزيره
التجاره وتنميه الصادرات وارجع الرئيس
التونسي فقدان مواد اساسيه اخرى او نقصها
في بعض مناطق في البلاد الى الاحتكار
والمضاربه غير المشروعه واتهم سعيد اطرافا
من دون تسميتها بالسعي لتاجيج الاوضاع
الاجتماعيه في البلاد والعمل على افتعال
الازمات
الى اسرائيل حيث اقتحم مجددا وزير الامن
القومي الاسرائيلي اتمار بن غفير اقتحم
ساحات المسجد الاقصى تحت حمايه الشرطه
الاسرائيليه حيث ان هذه العمليه هي عمليه
الاقتحام الثانيه له منذ ان اصبح وزيرا
للامن القومي بنغفير قال ان اسرائيل هي
الوحيده التي تملك الوصايه على القدس
واقتحام بن غفير دفع الناطق باسم الرئاسه
الفلسطينيه نبول نبيل ابو ردينه للرد حيث
قال ان اقتحام بنغفر للاقصى اعتداء سافر
وستكون له تداعيات خطيره وان تلك
الاقتحامات مرفوضه وستبوء بالفشل
محمود
من التوترات في القدس الى التوترات في
المشهد الانتخابي التركي حيث بدا الناخبون
الاتراك في الخارج التصويت في جوله
الاعاده للانتخابات الرئاسيه والتي ستنطلق
في الثامن والعشرين من مايو جاري من
المنتظر مشاهدينا تصويت الاتراك في
الممثليات التركيه خلال الفتره من العشرين
الى الرابع والعشرين من مايو وعلى ان
يستمر التصويت في المعابر الحدوديه
والمطارات حتى الثامن والعشرين من مايو
وهو اليوم الذي ستغلق فيه ابواب الاقتراع
مشاركه يبدو انها كبيره في صور هي الاولى
لانتخابات الاتراك في الخارج طوابير
الناخبين التي تنتظر التصويت في البعثات
التركيه خارج البلاد تنبئ بمنافسه حاده في
جوله الاعاده بين الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان
وزعيم المعارضه كمال كلجدار اوغلو اردوغان
الذي تقدم على منافسه بنحو مليونين ونصف
المليون صوت في الجوله الاولى اختار مناطق
الزلزال المنكوبه لبدء جولته الانتخابيه
وانتقد من هناك خصمه
نرى ان رئيسها حزب الشعب الجمهوري الذي
هزم في انتخابات الرابع عشر من مايو وفقد
الامل في 28 من مايو يستخدم لغه سامه
وقبيحه اكثر فاكثر انه يحول جزءا من
مجتمعنا الى عدو بتصريحاته المتهوره والتي
تحض على الكراهيه هي فرصه اردوغان للطعن
بخصمه كالجدار اوغلو زعيم حزب الشعب
الجمهوري بعد ردود فعل عنيفه من انصار
مرشح المعارضه ضد سكان الولايات التي
ضربها الزلزال بسبب تصويطهم لاردوكان على
وقع هذه التطورات قرر معسكر المعارضه
تصعيد لهجته بشكل كبير ضد اللاجئين بهدف
جذب اصوات القوميين من مؤيدين مرشح
الرئاسي سنان اوغان
سوريا
انتخابات الجوله الثانيه هي اختيار بين من
يتجنبون ترحيل السوريين ومن يخطط لترحيلهم
خلال عامين المعارضه تعتمد في خطابها ايضا
على الربط بين حزب الدعوه الحره او هدى
بار الداعم لاردوغان بحزب الله التركي وما
نفذه الحزب من اعمال تصنفها تركيا
بالارهابيه ورئيس اردوغان خلال الايام
الاخيره الماضيه هو يركز بشكل كبير على
شريحه الشباب بعد التصويت له في الجوله
الاولى في المقابل كريستيانو يحاول اللعب
على وتر القوميه من خلال معاداه اللاجئين
والهدف الاساسي هو كسب اصوات سنان اوغان
قبل اسبوع من جوله الاعاده ستلجا المعارضه
الى خطاب متطرف اكثر تجاه اللاجئين دون ان
تنسى العامل الاقتصادي الذي يراهن عليه
زعيم المعارضه خصوصا في المدن الكبرى تبدو
مهمه زعيم المعارضه اصعب في اقناع مزيدا
من الناخبين بالتصويت
له ثانيه خصوصا في ظل حيازه اردوغان
الاغلبيه بالبرلمان وخشيه الناخب من
التعارض بين السلطتين التنفيذيه
والتشريعيه فهل ستنجح خطابات المعارضه
المتشدده في تغيير مزاج ناخب ام ان خيار
الاستقرار والتوافق بين البرلمان والرئاسه
سيكون عاملا حاسما زيدان زنجلو العربيه
اسطنبول
اذا كان ذلك عن الانتخابات والوضع
الانتخابي في تركيا ولكن نعود الان الى
اقتحام وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي
اتمار بن غفير لساحات المسجد الاقصى تحت
حمايه الشرطه الاسرائيليه وحول ذلك تنضم
الينا من القدس مراسله العربيه لنا
كالغاصي اهلا بك معنا لانا لنتحدث بدايه
عن يعني التوقيت الذي اختاره بن غفير
الاقتحام باحات الاقصى للمره الثانيه طبعا
يعني كان هناك سابقا ربما تهديدات
لاقتحامه الساحات الاقصى خلال يعني مسيره
الاعلان ولكن هذا الاقتحام اتى ربما
مفاجئا لنا
اهلا بك فاطمه صحيح يعني فعليا نتحدث عن
اقتحام اثمر وهو وزير الامن القومي للمره
الثانيه بعد توليه هذا المنصب وجاء فعليا
هذا الاقتحام تحديدا بيوم الاحد صباحا اين
تحدث عن ربما لا يوجد اعداد كبيره من
المصلين في صباح يوم الاحد بشكل عام
تحديدا في هذه الساعات ويعني صاحبه ايضا
30 عنصر من عناصر الشرطه والقوات
الاسرائيليه التي يتم حمايته داخل ساحات
المسجد الاقصى وهو لم يقتحم ايضا لوحده
كان ايضا عدد من المستوطنين الذين اقتحموا
ساحات المسجد الاقصى وعلى ما يبدو انه قام
بتاجيل اقتحام المسجد الاقصى بسبب
التهديدات الفصائل الفلسطينيه يعني بسبب
كان هناك فعليا قبل عده ايام مسيره
الاعلام التي يحتفل بها المستوطنين
باحتلال القدس الشرقيه وت الشرقيه مع
القدس الغربيه ويعتبرونها عاصمه لاسرائيل
ويعني قبل عامين ايضا كان هناك تهديدات من
قبل الفصائل الفلسطينيه وتم اطلاق صواريخ
من قبل حماس حينما يعني بسبب فعليا مسيره
الاعلام وهذه المره على ما يبدو لم يسمح
من قبل الاجهزه الامنيه الاسرائيليه لبنك
فير وهو وزير امن القومي باقتحام ساحات
المسجد الاقصى تخوفا من تصعيد اكبر وتخوفا
من اطلاق صواريخ من قبل الفصائل ولذلك
مساحه المسجد الاقصى اثناء مسيره مسيره
الاعلام ولكن ماذا عن ردود الفعل يعني هل
ردود فعل داخليه حتى الان هل من ردود فعل
ربما دوليه يعني شاهدنا الناطق باسم
الرئاسه الفلسطينيه نبيل ابو ردينه رفض
هذا الاقتحام ويعني وصفه بالاعتداء السافر
وان له تداعيات خطيره ولكن ماذا عن ردود
الفعل المتبقيه
[موسيقى]
الى اربيل حيث يعقد اليوم اجتماع يضم
المكتبين السياسيين لحزبي السلطه في اقليم
كردستان العراق وذلك لحل الخلافات وابرزها
قانون انتخابات برلمان الاقليم وتوزيع
مقاعد الاقليات واشارت المصادر المشاهدين
الى ان الاجتماع سيكون الثاني من نوعه
خلال اسبوعين حيث سيبحث الخطوات التي
قطعها المكتبان الانتخابيان للحزبين في
مساله انتخابات برلمان كردستان بعد الفاصل
نتابع الهيئه السعوديه للفضاء تعلن اكتمال
الاستعدادات النهائيه قبل انطلاق رائدي
الفضاء السعوديين
الشباسكي يقر ضمنيا بسيطره روسيا على
بخموت بعد تجميدها بالكامل وبوتين يهنئ
مقاتلي فاجنر
ترحيب دولي بالهدنه الانسانيه في السودان
كان يناشد طرفي الصراع لاسكات المدافع
الهيئه السعوديه للفضاء تعلن اكتمال
الاستعدادات النهائيه قبل انطلاق راي
الفضاء السعوديين
متزايده الوزير الاسرائيلي بن غفير يتحدى
ويقتحم باحه المسجد الاقصى مجددا
احييكم من جديد ينطلق اليوم رائده الفضاء
السعوديان الى محطه الفضاء الدوليه في
رحله علميه تمثل حدثا تاريخيا سعوديا
وتدشن مرحله جديده لها في مجال الفضاء حيث
كشفت الهيئه السعوديه للفضاء عن اكتمال
الاستعدادات النهائيه لرائدي الفضاء
السعوديين واوضحت الهيئه ان صاروخ فالكن
تسعه ومركبه دراغون على منصه الاطلاق
استعدادا لنقل طاقم مهمه اي اكس 2 التي
تضم رائدي الفضاء السعوديين الى محطه
الفضاء الدوليه مبينه ان هذه الرحله تاتي
ضمن برنامج السعوديه للرواد الفضاء الذي
تم اطلاقه في الثاني والعشرين من سبتمبر
في العام 2022
وتتضمن اجراء اربعه عشره تجربه بحثيه
علميه رائده في بيئه الجاذبيه الصغرى
مستعدين للانقلاب
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
تختلف السعوديه نحو الفضاء السعوديه تدشن
مرحله جديده في مجال اهتمامها بالفضاء
رائد فضاء سعوديان ضمن مهمه اي اكس 2
والتي تنطلق باتجاه محطه الفضاء الدوليه
ريان برناوي وعلي القرني برفقه اخرين
امريكيين وهما جون شونر وبيجي
اختيارهما اتى بعد خضوعهما لتدريبات مكثفه
واختبارات حاسمه من قاعده كيب كان فيرال
الجويه في ولايه فلوريدا الامريكيه تنطلق
المهمه الفضائيه وتستمر مده 12 يوما
يقوم خلالها الفريق السعودي باربع عشره
تجربه علميه تتعلق بالدماغ والدم وعلوم
الخلايا اضافه لتجارب الاستمطار في
الجاذبيه الصغرى هذه المهمه تاتي ضمن
برنامج السعوديه للرواد الفضاء الذي اطلق
بهدف تعزيز مكانه السعوديه في مجال الفضاء
وتطوير قدراتها البشريه والصناعيه في
المجال
وتسعى هذه المبادره للابتكار والتميز
والتكامل بين مختلف قطاعات الفضاء والتي
تساعد في تاهيل كوادر سعوديه متمرزه لخوض
رحلات فضائيه طويله وقصيره المدى بجانب
المشاركه في التجارب العلميه والابحاث
الدوليه والمهام المستقبليه المتعلقه
بالفضاء العنود العبدلي العربيه
حول ذلك اكد رائد الفضاء السعودي علي
القرني في مقابله خاصه للعربيه بين هاء
التدريبات اللازمه لكيفيه التعايش في محطه
الفضاء الدوليه بالاضافه على كيفيه
استخدام الادوات التي ستمكنهم من اتمام
التجارب في الفضاء على حد قوله اتمنى
مؤخرا اجمال التدريبات المتعلقه بالرحله
وكانت بشكل عام التدريب على المهام
اليوميه التشغيليه لمحطه الفضاء الدوليه
تدربنا على مركزه الابحاث الاوروبي
والياباني كذلك
التدريبات مجملتا على كيفيه التعايش داخل
المحطه الفضاء الدوليه وكذلك محاكاه
للانطلاق والعوده التدرب على الادوات
المستخدمها ان شاء الله في الابحاث
العلميه والابحاث
العمليه ان شاء الله على متر المحطه
فهذه التدريبات بشكل عام تثبت او او
تمكننا من القدره على النجاح في هذه
المهمه وكذلك بعد المهمه ان شاء الله نعود
الى ارض الوطن محققين جميع الاهداف
المرجوه من هذه الرحله
اما ريانه برناوي اكدت في تصريحاتها
للعربيه انه سيتم عمل اربعه عشره تجربه
بحثيه علميه رائده لاول مره في التاريخ من
ضمنها تجارب معنيه للطلاب بالاضافه الى
تجارب خاصه بالخلايا المناعيه اكيد استاذ
اصلا مهمتنا بالاساس هي مهمه علميه فباذن
الله سنقوم باجراء 14 تجربه علميه بحثيه
رائده يعني لاول مره في التاريخ باذن الله
هذه التجارب تعنى بمجالات متعدده اولها هي
ثلاث تجارب توعويه تعليميه ستكون
لها علاقه بالتعاون مع الطلاب فهذه
التجارب كلها هدفها تحفيز الطلاب وتحفيز
الفضول لديهم في مجال الفضاء وباذن الله
سنقوم باجراء اربع تجارب علميه لها علاقه
بالخلايا المناعيه وهذه باذن الله حتكون
اول مره في التاريخ سنقوم بزراعه خلايا
مناعيه في بيئه الجاذبيه الصغرى بحيث انه
نزرع الخلايا ونضيف علاجات مختلفه عليها
ونشوف مدى استجابتها في بيئه الجاذبيه
الصوره وهذا البحث لاول مره يجرى في
التاريخ بدعم سمو سيدي حفظه الله
اتهم محامي مالك موقع تويتر محامي ايلون
ماسك الكس اتهمه شركه مايكروسوفت في رساله
باساءه استخدام بيانات الخدمه وطالب
بالتدقيق من قبل شركه البرمجيات العملاقه
[موسيقى]
مواجهه وشيكا ساحتها رقميه واسلحتها
خوارزميات هائله تلك هي الحروب العصريه
التي يصبح اغلى ما فيها المعلومات المشفره
انها المعركه القادمه بين عصفور ازرق يدعى
تويتر وشركه البرمجيه العملاقه مايكروسوفت
فتيلها اشتعل منذ ان غرد الملياردير
الامريكي ايلون ماسك قائلا انهم يستخدمون
بيانات تويتر بشكل غير قانوني وحان وقت
رفع الدعوه القضائيه وفي رساله تحذيريه
حملت ادعاءات غامضه وجهها اليكسسبيرو
محامي ملك تويتر الى الساتيا ناديلا
الرئيس التنفيذي لشركه مايكروسوفت تتمحور
حول تجاوز حجم الطلب المعقول لبيانات
تويتر بل حتى استخدامها بافراط واساءه
مضيفا ان الاتفاقيه التي عقدت بينهما
لتشرع هذا الكم الهائل من الاستخدام علما
بانهم استرجعوا اكثر من 26 مليار تغريده
في عام 2022 وحده هذا عدا عن ان الاتفاقيه
بينهما نصت على انه لا يحق لميكروسوفت
استرداد ايا من بيانات تويتر لاي كيان او
وكاله دون اختارهم مطالبا بالتدقيق المفصل
والممل للبيانات التي اخذتها من تويتر او
دمرتها ولاي تطبيق قدمتها ولماذا في
المقابل اكتفى المتحدث باسم مايكروسوفت
فرانك شو بان الشركه ستاخذ بالاعتبار
اسئله وطلبات تويتر
وسترد عليها بالشكل المناسب مؤكدا انهم
يتطلعون الى شراكه طويله الامد اسراء
الصغير العربيه
لقي مشاهدينا ما لا يقل عن عشره من
المشاركين في سباق سيارات لقوا مصرعهم
واصيب 9 اخرون في اطلاق نار مسلح في بلده
انسينادا المكسيكيه بالقرب من الحدود
الامريكيه بعد هجوم مسلح في منطقه سان في
سنتي واستهدف هؤلاء المشاركين في السباق
عندما كانوا متوقفين عند محطه وقود وذكرت
السلطات المحليه ان سياره رماديه حديثه
الطراز وصلت الى المنطقه الموجوده في
الطريق السريعه ونزل منها اشخاص بداوا في
اطلاق النار باسلحه طويله على المتسابقين
الى السينما السعوديه والتي تشارك العربيه
بشكل لافت معها في مهرجان كان السينمائي
في دورته السادسه والسبعين حيث تتوزع نحو
خمسه عشره مشاركه في كل المسابقات نصفها
في المسابقات الرسميه
توزعت سبعه افلام عربيه على مسابقات
مهرجان كارلا سينما الدولي بدورته لهذا
العام حيث يشارك لاول مره في تاريخ
المهرجان الفيلم السوداني وداعا جوليا
للمخرج محمد كردفاني تدور احداث الفيلم في
الخرطوم وقبيل انفصال الجنوب وينتمي الى
الدراما الاجتماعيه مع جانب تشويقيا بطابع
مستلهم من السينما الواقعيه
فيلم يمثل المغرب للمخرج اسماء المدير
يحمل عنوان كذب ابيض ويتحدث عن سيرتها
الذاتيه من خلال صوره تعثر عليها وهي مع
مجموعه اطفال في الدار البيضاء وتعود بها
ذكريات الى تفاصيل واحداث مرت بها وعن بعض
الاكاذيب التي سمعتها من جدتها لكنها كانت
اكاذي بيضاء هو بدا بصوره انا كل حكاياتي
التي حكيتها او ساحكيها تبدا من منطلق
صوره واحده هي بالصدفه لكن كذب ابيض ايضا
انطلق من سوره سوره قدمتها لوالدته عن
طفولتي
في المسابقه الرسميه بنات الفا للمخرج
كوثر بن هنيه ويعالج قصه حقيقيه عن اربع
بنات للام الفا يتم اغراؤهن للعمل مع
المنظمات الارهابيه وهو فيلم درامي وثائقي
فيلم مغربي اخر للمخرج كما الازرق كاشارك
في المسابقه الثانيه في المهرجان ويحمل
عنوان كلاب الصيد ويتحدث هذا الفيلم عن
حسن وعصام الابن والاب ويح
اليومي في احدى رواح الدار البيضاء
ويقومان باعمال خارج القانون لصالح هذا
المتنفذين ويحاولان ايجاد حل لمشكلتهما
جزء من المجتمع المغربي الذي لا يوجد حلول
ماديا
ويبحث عن
مشاريع خطيره كما سيعرض المهرجان فيلم
ببساطه مثل سيلفان للمخرج التونسيه
الكنديه منى شكري وهناك افلام اخرى خارج
المسابقه منها فيلم من الجزائر عمر
الفراوله ويروي الفيلم قصه الرجل عصابات
تجبره في الظروف على الفرار من فرنسا الى
وطنه الجزائر ويحكم عليه بالسجن لمده
عشرين عاما في الجزائر هذا العام الحضور
العربي في مهرجان كان هو الابرز سبعه
افلام في المسابقات الرسميه وشخصيات اخرى
توزعت على اللجنه التحكيم سعد المسعودي
العربيه مهرجان كان السينمائي جنوب فرنسا
في الختام نذكر دوما بالعناوين
يقرض ضمنيا بسيطره روسيا على بخموت بعد
تجميدها بالكامل وبوتين يهنئ مقاتلي فاجنر
ترحيب دولي بالهدنه الانسانيه في السودان
يناشد طرفي الصراع لاسكات المدافع
الهيئه السعوديه للفضاء تعلن اكتمال
الاستعدادات النهائيه قبل انطلاق رائدي
الفضاء السعوديين
في امان الله
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات